you are an incredible shape I have to
ask do you have any vices or anything
that you're doing that you shouldn't be
doing my biggest biggest vice right well
you know I got a lot of them but I'm
getting rid of them one by one
yeah but what I have not been able to
get rid of is cereal like sugary juice
I'm a foodie pebbles Captain Crunch the
whole thing and this is a weird thing I
don't like it for breakfast cuz I do
it's intermittent fasting things right
yeah but so I have it at night like I
eat my meals go from 2 to 10 but right
before bed I'll have some foodie pebbles
I'll have Captain Crunch
I will eat half a box and then it leaves
me with these big sugary dreams like I
have this one dream where it's like you
know Fred Flintstone and Captain Crunch
in a cage match and I'm going to beat
your urine must be rainbow color turns
the milk like this psychedelic colors
ooh I'll be my you can see the REM and
just like you know that my eyes are
going all over the place it's weird
these big sugary dream have you have you
had Cookie Crisp cereal oh my god what
genius thought of that man cereal that's
just chocolate chip cookie it came up
with it years ago but someone just said
oh it we're just gonna
I uh you know it comes from you know our
era you know Saturday morning cartoons
yes and my mother you just give us a
whole box of cereal because she could
sleep in yeah I mean we're like making
eggs or anything it was like cereal
here's your milk you know how to do that
right and so it's all in it's in my DNA
it's like saying here have something I'm
gonna give the kids some crack cocaine
let's take a quick break much more with
Terry Crews in a second stick around
[Applause]
you